aunque el ministro de defensa aseguró
que no había mayores irregularidades
durante la jornada de este domingo han
sido múltiples las denuncias que se han
conocido tanto en los centros de
votación como a través de las redes
sociales sobre todo el retraso en la
instalación de las mesas de votación la
apertura de los cierres incluso ha
pasado medio día todavía había mesas que
no estaban funcionando proselitismo
político afuera de algunos centros de
votación pero sobre todo en el estado
zulia han sido las denuncias más graves
se registró incluso un incidente en las
afueras de un centro de votación tras el
cual resultó una persona fallecida y dos
heridas por lo general a lo largo del
día debió a poca afluencia de electores
a las afueras de los centros de votación
sin embargo después de las seis de la
tarde todavía permanecían abiertos pues
había electores algunos de a las afueras
de estos centros de votación no fue sino
a través de 'twitter' que los rectores
del consejo nacional electoral
anunciaron el proceso de cierre de mesas
en años anteriores esto se hacía con una
transmisión en y radio y televisión se
esperan resultados pasadas las 10 11 de
la noche hora local estimamos que el
consejo nacional electoral pueda
pronunciar este primer boletín
recordemos que hoy se elegían en
venezuela- tanto alcaldes como
gobernadores autoridades de los consejos
municipales y asambleas legislativas una
elección trascendental por la oposición
no participaba desde el año 2017